[Music]
the summer learning loss is a term that
they used to describe the regressions
that kids in low-income neighborhoods
face relative to their affluent peers so
they say in lower-income neighborhoods
kids forget anywhere from two and a half
to three and a half months of what they
learned during this school year over the
summer while their middle class peers
break even or even make gains when I
first learned about the achievement gap
I was a freshman in college and I sort
of wanted to understand what the causes
of it were and as I started to do my
research I realized that there were a
thousand different reasons for the
achievement gap existed everything from
a lack of positive role models to poor
health conditions and so many of these
inner-city and low-income neighborhoods
and then I found this startling
statistic that said that two-thirds of
the achievement gap could be directly
attributed to unequal summer learning
opportunities or the summer learning
loss and low-income neighborhoods kids
forget anywhere from two and a half to
three and a half months of what they
learned over the summer from the school
year and so when they return to school
they're now two and a half to three and
a half months behind their affluent or
their middle-class peers
if you put just to put that in
perspective for you all the school year
from September to June is only ten
months long if a kid forgets two and a
half to three and a half months of what
they learned that's almost 25 to 35
percent of their learning teachers have
been reported that they spent anywhere
from a month and a half to two months
free teaching old material so if you add
that additional 20% you're talking about
50% of the kids learning so we sit here
and we ask ourselves why did is eighth
grader only have a fourth-grade reading
level and the truth of the matter is
that it theoretically speaking they've
only been in school for half the time
when I first learned about the summer
learning loss
I thought the obvious solution was
summer school right if kids were in
school over the summer then they
couldn't be regressing they couldn't
forget what they were learning and then
I learned really quickly that summer
school sucked it was punishment for the
kids and babysitting for the teachers
and I thought back to my own days when I
was in summer school and I didn't like
it and no one does there's such a
negative stigma associated with it when
I was 18 actually brought together a
group of friends to start to alleviate
some of the issues around summer
schooling in general I didn't think
learning had to be boring and so we
started to think about how
we could rebrand school and make school
more fun specifically like if we wanted
to go to school over the summer and we
were kids so we created a
multi-generational like near peer
learning model that has sort of changed
the way we interact with students and
children to change their learning over
the course of the summer so we recruit
and we hire near peer mentors kids who
are just a few years older than the kids
who are working with um to give them a
positive role model in their
neighborhood I used to think back to
when I was a child I didn't do bad
things because I wanted to be a bad kid
I did it because the older kids were
doing it so many times like the older
kids are the ones who are perceived as
being cool and kids are just looking for
an opportunity to be cool and fit in we
then paired them up with college
students who were aspiring educators
giving the near peer mentors now a new
role model to look up to I remember for
me it wasn't until my freshman year of
college that I built a relationship with
a college age student known in my family
had gone to college before and so as you
can imagine my college aspirations were
stunted or limited because of that and
then obviously for our college students
they're looking for some meaningful
professional development and growth as
well and so we hire teachers from the
schools that we work with who can act as
role models and mentors to our college
students who one day want to be in the
classroom and fill their shoes and so
this model where everyone is sort of a
participant but also beneficiary creates
this win-win-win situation for everyone
making summer school a lot more fun and
exciting when we first started our work
it was very structured we sort of said
this is what a six-week program looks
like in a low-income neighborhood or
community we quickly realized that no
two schools are the same and it's funny
we're primarily based in New York City
and as you think about like schools and
school districts in that area there's
about 1.1 million kids and there's 1,700
schools and so schools are co-located
within the same building and so schools
are oftentimes serving the same exact
population of kids with the same per
pupil spend the same amount of funding
yet they have very different cultures
and they lead to very different outcomes
and so one approach in one school may
not work for an approach with a very
different school so I think one we need
to stay away from these like overarching
generalizations about what's good for
is good for all because that's no longer
the case as it relates to summer
specifically I don't think we need to
get rid of the summer gap I think
there's an opportunity to do something
meaningful and different I always think
back to like our own programs and what
we do and I recognize that if we didn't
come in there with a completely
different approach to learning over the
summer that learning or extending this
school year in that case actually may
not make that much of a difference you
may not have regressions but that
doesn't mean you're gonna improve
student engagement or help kids catch up
and so I think the summer time is also
an opportunity to help kids catch up to
their other peers who may have retained
everything that they needed to learn for
this for the school year and probably
won't have a hard time continuing to be
independent learners we know the status
and so many of our low-income
neighborhoods where they're being raised
in single-parent households or immigrant
households like in my own household like
my mother not once picked up a book and
said hey you should be reading this book
because it's great level appropriate or
challenge yourself by doing this and I
think some of it is just she just didn't
know
and so being conscious of the fact that
there are certain disadvantages that
kids of color or minorities sort of
exhibit or deal with that their more
affluent peers just sort of don't have
to face does create an opportunity for
them over the summer and so I don't
think the solution is to close the
summer gap altogether but I do think
there are opportunities to maybe narrow
it a slight bit I know there are some
states in some cities that have summer
breaks that are as long as 14 weeks long
it's just way too long I think a
meaningful summer break is six to seven
weeks even with our programs our
interventions now are anywhere from four
to six weeks long and kids still have
three to four weeks off
[Music]